you see Jake I'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me you're just plain
boring again we are take on our very
loving relationship and it's midnight so
I guess I'm an amazing human slash
genius yeah although you might want to
read the inscription on that they're
built y ou know what does it say Amy
Santiago will you marry me
surprise
I saw refused I don't know what's
happening right now
I'm so confused I don't know what's
happening right now title your sex tape
oh my god I'm shaking I'm definitely
gonna cry title your sex tape
wait is this really happening is this
part of the heist if this is part of the
heist I will dump you so hard no please
it's like it's really happening
okay it's not part of the heist I
promise this is you are I love how
beautiful you are
I love your face and I love your but I
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on I love how much you
pretend to like die hard I like the
second one you don't have to okay yeah
you're kind and you're funny and you're
the best person I know and the best
detective also for reals I love your
butt I love yours too you gross Amy
Santiago will you marry me Jake Peralta
I will marry you
thank you so much hey sure goes this
little [ __ ] escape so that I teach
did you just mm-hmm did you say mm-hmm I
heard you were out here really hate
those Jets huh not a child I don't need
a bubble bath
so listen before you say anything I want
to say I'm sorry you're sorry wow I
can't believe I almost made Terry do
this apology accepted I was so eager to
make up for all the joshing Ron I've
missed
I forgot this getaway is really for you
detectives and one of the things just
driving to get away from he's your
captain yeah I mean it's nothing against
you as a person everyone loves you but
you're our captain and normally we get
really drunk and act like crazy idiots
and play stupid games where we make fun
of the boss which is hard when the boss
is present yeah but not impossible I
think instead of us rising to your level
it's maybe time for you to stoop down to
ours
and that's just the standard is this
seat taken
you really gotta do this do yes my name
is Rachel Weinstein I'm a graduate
student on sabbatical to study birds at
the University of Buenos Aires
you know Cornell has a far better
ornithology department and it's right
here in New York Cornell has accused me
of robbing a bank and it's gonna send me
to jail for 15 years I guess would
robbing the metaphor I don't know why
you're here you're not gonna change my
mind I know I just wanted to say goodbye
okay goodbye I hope you know your
family's gonna miss you I don't care I'm
Billie speak to them I was talking about
the nine-nine he's safer it's a
Weinstein
[Music]
where are Jake and Rosa I don't know I'm
getting worried because the jury's
getting restless
especially juror number four she'd
rather be in Lake Havasu with her new
boyfriend Derek I didn't get that from
her face I was eavesdropping by the
vending machine so I just got a text
from Peralta he's a few minutes away in
DES perhaps a bit more than a few
minutes away I think there's a joke I'm
here sorry traffic was a nightmare
coming back from Philadelphia
cheesesteak restaurant they do breakfast
too checks out okay so what happened I
guess I wasn't ready to say goodbye to
my family good neither will we
I know what I'm picking up on is just a
genuine moment a friendship and respect
and now I'm feeling like you wish I
would stop analyzing you because I'm
ruining a moment but you guys are so
good I love you what are you doing here
I wanted to say I'm sorry I reacted
poorly last night this is all new to me
I know it's also not new you know I'm
still the same person I always was well
I don't feel I know that person dad my
fault not yours I wanted to be able to
tell me everything I can't promise you
all understand but I'm trying I want you
to know that I accept you for who you
are and I love you very very much
I love you too
so have you been on any dates with women
yeah dad we didn't talk about my dating
life before we don't need to talk about
it now
you're good good you're right sors mom
mom needs a little more time Thanks
yes family game nights gonna be kind of
weird you know what means that maybe we
better put game night on a hole for a
little while okay I'm gonna let you get
back to work okay
[Music]
what's going on family game night don't
worry I brought twister lifetime you and
I would have made a hot-ass couple
agreed yes you should be very proud of
yourself I know things aren't exactly
where you want to be right now but I
promise you they will improve Thank You
captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are the world becomes a better more
interesting place so thank you hey do
you seriously only have two wine glasses
yeah a little loan well you're gonna
need to get some more cuz there's a lot
of us here thank you for doing this man
of course we'll be here every week
rotella i broke both your wine glasses
in your fridge door in your bathroom
every single week
squad if I could have your attention
please I'm being transferred to the
public relations office I'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately hell I
don't understand what the hell why are
you doing this what the hell I want to
say it has been a pleasure to have
worked alongside all of you for the past
21 and a half months I'm sorry for
getting so emotional pretty consistent
tone actually these have been the these
have been the best years of my career no
no this is new and I know that every one
of you give me everything you had
and I will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
meet more see dismissed sir I'm coming
with you
Thank You Gina I'm also coming not
necessary we are here today to celebrate
the marriage of Jake Peralta and Amy
Santiago I've known you both for the
last five years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolved into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage I'm proud of you and I
love you both
permission to say it back permission
granted I love you sir
lovey captain now I believe you prepared
your own vows
yes I was going to do an Addams Family
theme drap but my beatboxer isn't here
that's the only reason it's not
happening so Ames today has been a crazy
day but I shouldn't be surprised because
we've had a lot of crazy days there was
our first date our first kiss the first
time you told me you loved me
and the day you told me you would marry
me also yesterday and the day before
that and the day before that because
every single day that I get to be with
someone as amazing as you is crazy to me
I love you and I'm worried about dancing
in front of our friends at the end okay
well
I've been planning this wedding for the
last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong I would have had a panic attack
that sent me into the ER but I'm here
and I've never been happier life is
unpredictable not everything's in our
control but as long as you're with the
right people you can handle anything and
you Jake Peralta are the right person
for me but I do have some bad news there
is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt your butt is the bomb
there will be no survivors I love you so
much you're my dream girl I love you too
and can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with you
you